the demographic time bomb
some of the world's biggest economies
Italy Germany Japan and China are aging
they're running out of workers with
potentially disastrous economic and
social consequences how can Nations deal
with volatile demographic pressures and
will these pressures transform the
global balance of power for decades to
come
[Music]
demographics rule the world
the exact combination of young and old
workers and retirees can determine a
country's economic future
every country has a demographic sweet
spot where the majority of your
population is of working age so they're
both producing and they're consuming
great for the economy
well demographics are very important put
bluntly for advanced economies the more
people there are the larger the economy
is likely to be and the more power and
influence they like to wield on the
global stage and that's why the US is a
global leader and it's why European
countries club together to influence
policy on a global level
the population of the planets doubled
twice in the 20th century meaning the
world was able to create more wealth
so in 1965 there were about 3.3 billion
people on the planet now is about 7.3
that's just just 50 years later so
that's obviously had an enormous effect
on the productive capacity of the
economy in total but as well as growing
the world's population is aging
the average age of all the people on
Earth at the start of this decade was 32
by the end of this Century it will be
42.
by 2035 1.1 billion people will be over
the age of 65.
this graying of the planet has
potentially profound economic
implications
as the population ages it means there
are more people consuming goods and
services and fewer people producing them
so simply there's just a bit less to go
around and overall that means that
economy with an aging population is
going to be growing slower than it
otherwise would it was aging happens
people are going to save less they're
going to spend more and that's
potentially going to push up interest
rates quite significantly over the next
few decades and if you look at analysis
from former bank of England Economist
Charlie Bean he says that's about to
happen roughly right now where just at
that inflection point where demographics
start to push up interest rates rather
than push down on
many of the countries with the fastest
growing working age populations are in
Africa or Southeast Asia
these countries are about to enter a
demographic window that is going to be
very supportive of producing economic
growth India is uh in the early parts of
a demographic sweet spot where the
majority of their population is now of
working age this really helps support
growth
India right now in 2016 is projected to
be one of if not the fastest growing
economy in the world the demographic
factors are a big Tailwind to that
growth
but for more mature developed economies
the demographics are more complex and
potentially very worrying for some
economies particularly in Europe who are
extremely indebted the slowing growth of
the workforce or the shrinking of the
workforce means that those debts become
less sustainable so it actually adds to
pressures that those economies are
facing and in particular you've got sort
of Italy in that camp but actually
extends to Germany as well while that's
not indebted the the demographic
pressures facing Germany are actually
quite significant
demographic currents can seem invisible
and slow moving but they affect many of
the day-to-day decisions of our
governments
I think that decisions may need to be
made do do we accept the fact that
we we do have aging demographics this
will create headwinds thus producing
growth or do we accept the fact that we
we need to accept immigrants to
rejuvenate to make the population
younger
countries that are really old if they
want to solve this problem has to ask
themselves how many immigrants do you
let in before it actually is a cultural
revolution within your country the way
of life that you're used to is going to
change
demographic Trends pose similarly
dramatic problems for workers
as the population is aging it's also
living longer and healthier lives so the
expectancy probably should be that
people who are able to work will
continue to work for a bit longer and I
think to just simply to maintain the the
continued growth of living standards or
material living standards we've seen
over the past 50 years or so people will
have to work for longer
Stephen Chan is an expert in
international politics he thinks current
trends in population point to a very
different world to come a world where
even powerful economies like Japan and
China face potentially catastrophic
demographic challenges
over the next half century you are going
to see major demographic shifts there's
going to be major expansions of
population I think we may well be
entering an era not so much of Despair
that may come but certainly an era to
come shortly of great frustration
because of demographic pressures
[Music]
demographic Trends are changing our
world
for Stephen Chan these offer a unique
insight into Global economics and
politics
Professor Chan has taught in North
America Europe Africa and Asia and has
served as a diplomat and advisor to the
UK foreign office and U.S state
department and his fascination with how
movements of people can affect movements
in international Affairs stems from his
own upbringing
my parents were refugees during World
War II somehow they've found their way
to New Zealand and they were told by the
ship captain you guys better get out
there's nothing south of here but
Penguins so the appreciation of the need
for people to keep moving around the
world that's always been with me what I
find surprising is how people seem to
imagine that you can live in a world
without demographic shifts
in our globalized world demographics
matter
some countries will have too many people
leading to internal pressures and
migration others will have too few
leading to a shrinking working age
population there are going to be immense
demographic changes
increasingly disturbing age profiles and
many of these countries and of course
demographic shifts as populations spill
over from one country to another the
migrant World Refugee crisis for
instance is a case in point and of
course there are very very difficult
concerns to do with aging workforces for
instance not enough young people coming
on stream onto the market not enough
people educated to the extent that would
be required to fulfill the technocratic
requirements of the future world
China the world's most populous country
has grappled with demographic crises for
much of the last 50 years
since the days of Chairman Mao its
governments have employed differing
strategies to handle the nation's
changing demographic trends
German mile was not the world's greatest
technocratic planner he would have
sudden winds and almost swings of mood
but I think that there was an initial
very traditional Chinese impulse to
become powerful by having a very great
number of people this is something which
has a cultural ancestry now in fact it
was never viable to grow Beyond a
certain point even during the early
years of the Communist Revolution there
were vast food shortages
[Music]
people you have the more the state must
provide for the people within so it's
actually a burden to the state to have
too many people that's why China decided
to review the policy of growing a
population and of course went completely
to The Other Extreme to try to restrict
the growth of the population
the one child policy reversed Mao's
plans with dramatic results
[Music]
China's fertility rate the number of
births per woman per lifetime was 5.9 in
the early 1970s
today it has fallen below 1.6
demographers estimate a country needs a
fertility rate of 2.1 to maintain a
stable population
China is now on the edge of a
demographic Cliff with potentially huge
social consequences I think when we look
at China today we're going to be looking
at a leadership that realizes that
continuing a one-child policy is going
to lead to nothing but long-term
difficulties particularly when you have
an aging population with no one to look
after them because there's only one
child you don't have as it were a mass
of children or an extended family with
masses of children who can do the
looking after and then this aging
population becomes a weight on the
aspirations of the younger ones
but the biggest problem is only now
becoming apparent China's working age
population started to fall in 2012.
the world's second largest economy is
losing workers
by 2025 there will be 316 million
Chinese over the age of 60.
that's almost equivalent to the entire
population of the United States today
in 2015 China abandoned the one-child
policy
I think China does have major concerns
for the immediate future the medium term
future you're going to have this
interval which could be as long as 20
years before these children grow up and
are educated and are able to participate
in a more competitive Workforce so until
that happens there's going to be a drain
not only in terms of having to invest in
the education of these young people but
whether or not the state can support the
older people who are retiring before the
younger generation comes to economic
maturity it can help look after them
thank you
believes China's demographics need not
be fatal the growth may be slowing for
some time
the Chinese economy continues to grow
perhaps not a Breakneck speed but it has
to continue to grow in such a way that
it continues to provide employment to
people in terms of the Chinese impact on
the rest of the world provided the
Chinese still have enough foreign
exchange to keep buying our
manufacturers well I don't think we're
going to have a problem and certainly
we're going to continue to buy Chinese
manufacturers your card walked out of
High Street in Europe these days without
having no choice but to buy clothes made
in China
China's government is now expecting the
nation's population to Peak in 2020
before starting to fall
in Japan the fall has already started
between 2010 and 2015 its population
shrank by 947 345.
by the end of this Century the UN
expects the country's population to fall
from 127.1 million to just 83 million
other estimates suggest the population
could more than halve to just 52 million
compounding the demographic crisis is
culture
Japan has got a whole Gathering a whole
collaboration almost of problems to do
with demographic shifts to do with an
aging population certainly but to do
with all kinds of social trends and
social habits which no government in
Japan wishes to address the culture of
seniority in Japan denies flexibility
for younger workers the very very strict
as it were social Customs that inhibit
the full participation of women in the
workforce further restricts their
flexibility and then the very very
strict rules on when you can begin
taking out your pension means that
people are stuck unproductively and work
they no longer want to do they don't
want to learn new ways of doing things
and they become as much a drain at work
as they would be to the state if they
left work and into retirement
Japan has so far resisted turning to one
of the great consequences of and
possible solutions to recent demographic
Trends migration
I think one of our problems is that we
always thought that globalization would
be on our terms but now there's a
multi-faceted globalization where there
are pressures from many many Global
players in different parts of the world
I don't think that we're now going to be
able to put the genie back into the
bottle in terms of Greater Transit from
the Middle East and North Africa to
Europe that is a phenomenon which I
think is going to remain with us in one
way or another but numbers will grow
numbers will increase coming from those
parts of the world to Europe
[Music]
several EU countries have their own
demographic problems
the German government expects one-third
of the population to be over the age of
65 by 2060. Europe's largest economy
needs to find more workers
and those already in work should be
prepared to work longer and retire later
the extension of the working age is
always going to be one of these big
political hot potatoes but it's not just
a case of making people stay in
employment it has to be a certain sort
of employment how can you create the
kinds of jobs that will not only give
people employment but keep them employed
in a highly productive fashion and I
mean highly productive in terms of the
expectations of the middle part of the
21st Century
three of the four biggest economies in
the world China Japan and Germany are
facing major demographic challenges
the choices they make increasing
fertility accepting large-scale
immigration or delaying their workers
retirement will determine whether they
remain among the most powerful nations
in the world in the decades to come
demographic Trends are Rippling across
Europe the continent's biggest economy
is facing a population crisis Germany
has the most over 65s in the EU the
economy is already experiencing skilled
shortages in some areas
at automaker Daimler over 100 retired
workers like Emil keneil have been
rehired to plug the gaps
also families outside
[Music]
the program acknowledges that older
workers have valuable skills
[Music]
is
for more physical tasks Daimler has
modified some of its production lines to
make them more sympathetic to aging
limbs
16 here in Hindi and Uber cop Store The
Uber cop stool had in Fertile gagan
Riverside
um distance
Daimler expects half its staff to be
over 50 by 2024.
um
whilst German businesses prepare for an
older Workforce elsewhere in Europe
immigration offers another way to defuse
the demographic time bomb
this is satriano in Italy a town at the
heart of Europe's demographic crisis
populations
[Music]
Italy's birth rate has been falling for
50 years and is at the lowest level
since unification in 1861.
the Italian government is now paying
Villages like satriano to take in
migrants from around the world the hope
is that new blood will stem satrianos
and Italy's demographic decline
La presence
the journeys made by many of the new
arrivals like Adnan a testament to the
demographic flows sweeping the globe
Premier League
what a chip
is important
[Music]
conditions
it's too early to say if this kind of
managed migration will reverse Italy's
demographic fortunes but it has made
satriano a livelier place and serves as
a reminder that demographic Trends have
touched every community in the world at
some time in the past
yes
Italian
demographic shifts are occurring all the
time in every country being able to
anticipate them early enough is the key
to a nation's future prosperity
you could boil it down this way
when you have citizens there's two ways
they could add to the economy they could
produce and they can consume when you
have too many people above a certain age
and they leave the labor force suddenly
you have people in your economy who are
consuming but are no longer producing
this makes it much harder for a country
to grow governments that don't have an
long-term wise policy
will face demographic consequences or
rather their successes will face
demographic consequences I think that
those countries that have got policies
that are able to cater for their
demographic changes are the ones that
are going to be successful in the future
our world is a divided and unequal place
in a competitive economy you'll always
have some inequality and obviously
you'll have those who are very
successful and some who are less so but
the issue is the extreme one percent of
the wealthiest population holds more
than half of the world's wealth
62 wealthiest people hold the same kind
of wealth as the lowest 50 percent of
the world population it's a very
striking statistic indeed if we look at
CEO pay you know it's gone from about 50
times the average worker 30 years ago to
300 times now potentially not only does
it issue for investors it's also an
issue for for workers
inequality has become the hot button
economic issue of the 21st century but
worrying about inequality is not new
if we look way back into U.S history we
saw dramatic income inequality and for
instance the Gilded Age the 1880s and
the 1890s and it went so far and then it
collapsed and policies were put in place
by a number of presidents and
administrations to sort of equalize the
playing field labor laws were put in
place tax laws were changed and that
prevailed through the course of World
War II and into the 1960s
but then by the 1980s tax laws were
changed and the economy had changed and
so from the early 1980s to present we've
seen income inequality uh on the rise it
matters because uh income inequality
eventually contributes uh to wealth
inequality with wealth comes power in
terms of politics and corporate
leadership and lots of different uh
facets of the economy and so when uh
much wealth is held by a very few
individuals within an economy or within
a country then those individuals tend to
have an outsized degree of control over
economic and political policy making and
therefore they are able to incorporate
policies that will even further increase
their levels of wealth
[Music]
quality is about more than fairness
economists worry extreme levels of
inequality can have dramatic effects on
the finances of Corporations and
governments
it really affects the pace at which will
the world economy is growing so to give
you an example the wealthiest as they
get more money they tend to spend less
of a marginal dollar so this way you get
less consumption and consequently uh
less growth and in the economy so that's
one uh kind of a consequence another
thing is that lower and medium income
families tend to borrow more to support
their consumption and it creates risks
some of the most dramatic levels of
inequality can be seen in the developing
World here inequality appears to have a
corrosive effect on the whole economy
something else that we've seen in
immersion markets is a correlation
between inequality and Corruption levels
where government is not effective you
are necessarily getting education in
place and the rules to allow everyone to
succeed if you look at the Arab Spring
in North Africa and the Middle East you
know at root cause was you know Economic
Opportunity and so if you have this
extreme inequality if you have a lack of
Economic Opportunity you know you could
potentially have a political unrest
if you're at the top of the pile it's
tempting to think inequality does not
affect you but this may be dangerously
complacent
clearly inequality is very bad for the
people at the bottom especially if the
bottom is very low I think at the top
there's a potential risk to you know
what what could extreme inequality breed
could it lead to political unrest could
it lead to to new rules new taxation so
I think you know in the short term even
if you're at the the top of the economic
permit you may be very happy with your
position but long term I think there's
potential for for change which may be
destabilizing
think about it in a
in a thing because that actually could
impact economic growth in in the world
so I would say that it's a it's a
problem for everybody
one Global Economist is convinced
inequality is dramatically affecting
human life in even the richest parts of
the world and that if we want to
maximize growth and social cohesion it's
an issue we can no longer ignore
absolute income inequalities where I
think we have to have a real debate
there are clear knock-on effects and
whether there are an education Access
Health Care options but also political
and life expectancy challenges it's very
much the case that income inequality is
now a driver in some of these other
factors
[Music]
inequality is one of the most hotly
debated issues in economics from New
York to Nairobi dambisa moyo is a global
Economist her work for the World Bank
and on Wall Street has seen her named
one of the most influential people in
the world
fascinated by the biggest Trends in
economics from the politics of
development in Africa to the price of
Commodities in China
now she's turning her attention to
inequality
income inequality is a particularly
problematic in as much as it is a
defining factor in many societies for
where a society's living standards are
going
the data on income inequality has shown
that it has gotten worse over the last
several decades
in fact over the past 30 years we have
seen income inequality worsen across the
United States the United Kingdom and
across much of Europe
in the same vein we've seen that the
average income of the top one percent in
the United States today is 30 times the
average income of the rest of the
populations and that rest of the 99
compare this with 30 years ago with 1978
when it was simply 10 times higher for
the top one percent
[Music]
economists worry that inequality ushers
in a range of social problems
recent studies in Mexico suggest that
neighborhoods with high levels of
inequality may suffer more violent crime
than those where inequality is less
pronounced
researchers in other nations have come
to similar conclusions
a problem with income inequality is the
implications and impact that it has on a
society and the question being is it
possible for people of different income
levels and without prospects of
improving their lives to live cheek by
Zhao for example in the United States
the Bronx is the poorest congressional
district in the United States but it's
also 20 minutes by train about five
stops to one of the richest enclaves in
the world in the upper east side of
Manhattan
there are real questions around whether
that's sort of a living cheek by gel is
actually long-term sustainable given
risks of crime and also destitution
there are knock-on effects for other
forms of inequality such as health or
education and of course political
inequality
in the United States approximately 158
families are responsible for
approximately 50 percent of campaign
funding around the U.S election system
and that really does pose the question
about where democracy stands and how
that might play in to the political
representation of the democratic process
Americans have always prided themselves
on levels of social mobility within
their country the ability of people to
get ahead whatever circumstances they
were born into
but some recent evidence suggests this
is changing
there is a more fundamental aspect to
dealing with the income inequality
challenge which I would argue revolves
around social mobility and social
Mobility really is about people's belief
and people's access and opportunity to
improving their living standards and
their livelihoods over them a period of
time I think that the cause of income
inequality is the breakdown of social
Mobility particularly in the western
societies so just to give you a flavor
for that today in the United States if
you are born into the bottom 20 percent
of the income level then you have only
five percent chance of ending up your
life in the top 20 without a college
degree clearly that suggests that income
inequality is widening but I think also
it shows that there's a real issue
around social mobility and people's
ability to actually transform their
lives and to move into higher levels of
income
as well as hindering social Mobility
extreme levels of income inequality May
depress growth across whole economies
the reason that this is so important is
that the oecd estimates that this is
costing those developed countries
approximately eight and a half percent
GDP points um over this period so put
another way because of income inequality
and the widening effects of the gap
between the richest and the poorest in
the U.S and across Europe we have seen
GDP growth slow by about 8.5 percent
over the past 25 years
today there are real concerns about how
this bodes for the longer term and for
the future a lot of projections now show
that economic growth will be slowing and
obviously the knock-on effects of income
inequality are likely to be worse
this means inequality is not just a
problem for those at the bottom of the
economic pile
chronic income inequality May well
affect the social and economic health of
everyone
[Music]
if you are wealthy and living in a in an
urban setting for example
um the fact that you every day are
dealing with people who have a lower
income levels but more importantly have
fewer prospects to improve their
livelihoods has an absolute and direct
impact on your safety but also on your
own living standards to the extent that
society as a whole will not likely be
growing and so it's not just about lower
living standards for those that
proportion of society it's about lower
living standards for its entirety in the
society because the growth of a society
is highly linked to how the average
person in society is performing
[Music]
dambisa believes the key to tackling
inequality lies in reactivating Social
Mobility but to do that citizens basic
needs in terms of health and education
must be catered for first
I think that the thing that is a
Paramount an urgency is to ensure that
all citizens and particularly people who
are at the lower levels of income are
seeing improvements in their living
standards over the longer period of time
the real underlying challenges of income
inequality in a broader sense which I
would argue really are hitched to the
idea of social mobility and the
challenges there
but social Mobility is propelled by
economic growth and without economic
growth inequality will rise
just to be absolutely clear on that we
need to aim for at least seven percent
GDP growth every year in order to double
per capita incomes in one generation we
are far below that Target so it's really
the case that we do have real issues
around with the long-term prospects for
economic growth are but therefore what
the long-term prospects for social
mobility and our ability to reduce
income inequality are
the problem of inequality is worrying
for the west then it's compounded in
countries with fast-growing young
populations if these economies are to
have any chance of tackling inequality
they must create millions of jobs first
Beyond just the developed countries of
course there's a real concern around
income inequality widening particularly
in the faster growing largest emerging
market economies such as Brazil India
South Africa today they're approximately
85 million young people mainly in the
Emerging Markets between the ages of 18
and 25 that are out of work if we are
going to try and solve the income
inequality challenge we first have to
make sure we've got growth but we also
have to make sure that we are providing
incomes that are growing
um to this young population
we also have to make sure that people
have improved access to education and to
health care so that they have the social
infrastructure to improve their lives
and therefore support social Mobility
without those factors there is a real
risk that living standards of not just
the impoverished percentage of the
population but society as a whole starts
to deteriorate
[Music]
South Africa is one of the most unequal
countries in the world
here the consequences of inequality on
the safety of society are visible and
real
but businesses are trying to restart
social mobility and save the economy
inequality is one of the defining
challenges of our age
in South Africa the most unequal country
on the continent its consequences can be
seen in the continuing Poverty of large
parts of the country
and in the visceral fear of crime that
defines the wealthiest suburbs
taking a look at the big picture uh and
the the well-being of a country in the
long run it is very unhealthy to have
this dramatic distribution of of wealth
and inequality it will not be a
successful model to live in a world
where the haves are isolated into
communities with very high walls around
those communities while the have-nots
are sitting at the gates uh begging for
table scraps
together
in South Africa there are more private
security guards than police officers
they Patrol the country's gated suburbs
under the most visible example of an
unequal Society
crime is bad in your home out of your
home
basically all over and I want it to
sound like it's terrifying we live with
it and we have good lives here however
trying to keep your family safe trying
to keep your home safe has become more
and more difficult and that is what we
focus on
CSS tactical is a johannesburg-based
private security firm employing 750
people
so our approach is very much multiple
layers of security so you would have
your armed response you would have your
product of trading so the vehicle is not
just sitting under a tree waiting to be
dispatched they're actually present in
the area they're patrolling they're
driving up and down street and we've got
very intelligent software that actually
alerts on unusual behavior so if you're
walking down the streets five o'clock in
the afternoon going home from work
that's normal but three o'clock in the
morning on that side of the street is
abnormal so there's again a tension on
what is going on in the suburb as
opposed to just sitting under a tree
waiting for an alarm to go off
fear of crime is splitting Johannesburg
in two
the city experienced over 21 000
burglaries last year
Johannesburg is the financial Capital so
hence a greater concentration of I guess
wealth and wealthy people and lots of
stuff to steal lots of stuff that can
that you can see to steal there's a
massive difference between the Haves and
the have-nots I mean the unemployment is
Rife and I think
unfortunately people have not seen that
you know crime is is a way to make a
living
South Africa is now more unequal than it
was under apartheid but some businesses
across the country are actively trying
to address this and get social Mobility
moving again
so I was pregnant with my first daughter
and I was at home we lived in a farm so
I was at home during the day and I would
chat to the ladies that worked in the
fields next door and that sort of thing
and they were picking lettuces and
whatever but they really had you know
that they were they had so much inside
of them but they had no opportunity to
go anywhere there was an opportunity for
training or to to get a bit further or
anything and also what I realized there
was no power of possibility
Aaron along with her sister Maeve
decided to set up mangwanani a health
spa
their plan was to recruit their staff
from among the rural poor
it was literally there's a couple of
ladies from the field next door so
everybody went home and found sisters
and aunts and whatever they were
unemployed and of course we trained them
up I realized the importance and what
mangonani could actually do in South
Africa I realized that very very quickly
and realizing then the amount of lives
you could change
Christine budilezi was one of the first
women that Erin and Maeve employed
I was on my way I remember one weekend
going to church then I met a Maeve who
gave me a lift and she started chatting
to me are you working what are you doing
at the moment I was still at school and
everything then I said to her no
currently I'm working at a farm it was a
chicken farm where you were we were paid
like 20 rent a day then she said but why
don't you come and join mangonania then
after a week I said you know what I've
got nothing to lose so I went for my
training then from there started working
at the spa as a therapist I started from
the bottom like doing massages which I
really enjoyed it then within three
months and I moved into
becoming one of the treaty managers and
then I think within a year I was
promoted to be a general manager which
for me it was such a growth in such a
small time
has become a prolific job creation
scheme expanding across South Africa and
propelling women like Christine from
rural poverty to senior managerial
positions
we estimate that we've trained about 20
000 people we had ladies that had been
with us for say eight nine years and it
really reached the top they were now
managers and I'm also proud to say that
every single one of our Spas is run by a
lady who came up through the ranks
Aaron is going further rolling out plans
across her 20s bars to give shares in
the business to its employees
at the moment in kwazulu-natal our staff
owned 30 percent of their business I
wanted them to be part of the business
because when you're doing that many
treatments in a day you're giving so
much of yourself
by training staff giving them a route to
move up the pay grades and offering the
mistake in their own business Aaron
hopes her firm can help tackle
inequality in South Africa
I can look after my kids I can look
after my family you know with us black
communities we've got so many families
that we take care of like I'm a
breadwinner at home everybody depends on
me as much as you've got the other
people that are working but most of the
time I'm the one who's taking that whole
responsibility so mango Nani has given
us
like growth like giving us hope
it has made us like dreamers
inequality has come to Define South
Africa's economy but if more can be done
to reactivate social Mobility there's a
chance that this will not be the case
for long
when households are really in a grinding
state of poverty they can't contribute a
whole lot to economic well-being so what
as lower income demographics are lifted
up into working class or middle class
thresholds they tend to be better
educated there's less crime there's a
stronger family structure and they tend
to be a lot more productive in terms of
the economy and they also consume and
invest a lot more as well a strong
middle class a strong working class is
really the backbone of a healthy
democracy I feel I'm cautiously
optimistic about the future I believe
that the path towards a world of
economic growth of social mobility and
improved income inequality statistics is
one that is possible but not without
there being hard choices whether it's
increasing economic growth increasing
social Mobility we have to make sure
that we're addressing those factors to
avoid a situation where society and the
members of the society become so
disaffected
[Music]
fossil fuels have built our world coal
and oil found deep within the Earth are
carbon-rich resources which pack a
mighty punch
they're abundant they're easy to
transport and store
if we were ending up with fossil fuels
we couldn't have had an industrial
revolution a lot of our agriculture
would be impossible we'd probably have
great difficulty feeding our current
population never mind having smartphones
and electricity and all these things
certainly it would have been difficult
to build our civilization without fossil
fuels
nearly 100 million barrels of oil are
used around the world every day
in 2014 fossil fuels accounted for 85
percent of world energy consumption
but governments are worried about
climate change and pollution
we see this in the world cities from
Shanghai to Mumbai and even to New York
Paris London air pollution is becoming
an increasingly important issue
politically and of course you've also
got climate change increasingly policy
makers world over recognize the need to
act
fossil fuels present a political
challenge for the West
the biggest oil reserves are found in
regions which are often hostile or
unstable
as well as political worries consumer
habits are changing
historically the energy system has been
driven by big investment decisions made
by big energy companies supported by
government and increasingly consumers
have more choice to enables them to make
energy to decisions of their own for
example they might choose to put solar
on their roofs they might choose to
invest in the increasing number of of
energy storage options they might buy an
electric vehicle until recently we were
we were sort of dumb consumers we had no
information about what we were buying
how much we were using and that's that's
changing very rapidly
but removing fossil fuels from our
Energy Mix is a daunting task one which
could potentially Shake our economies to
their core
if we flip to switch overnight and
switched from fossil fuels to Renewables
I think there would be widespread chaos
because honestly we haven't really
figured out even how we would do it
but the cost of energy is changing the
financial shocks of the early 21st
century may have disrupted the economics
of the energy Market
having a financial crisis had two
effects the first was it generated over
190 billion US dollars of stimulus
funding for the green economy industrial
output fell electricity and energy
demand fell households became more
Thrifty they were more mindful of their
energy consumption they started thinking
about ways to reduce their bills but you
combine weaker Demand with more
renewable energy and what you created
was the beginnings of the disruption
that we currently Witness
the results of this disruption can be
seen around the world
so as of 2014 Greece was generating 9.5
percent of its electricity from solar
Italy were generating 8.7 and Germany
6.3 percent of its electricity from
solar now those are not massive numbers
but they do illustrate that you can have
a real economy that runs substantially
off intermittent Renewables without the
sky forming
solar itself has come down about 75 in
the last five years
wind energy has got about 25 cheaper
over the last five years so those two
technologies are now competing directly
with the more traditional conventional
sources of electricity now the question
is how do you integrate a system which
has variable and intermittent Supply and
increasingly choppy demand and the
technical side of how do you make that
work in a much lower carbon environment
Tony sieber is a writer academic and
renewable energy investor who believes
not only will we make Renewables work
but that we are already in the midst of
an energy disruption which by 2030 will
signal the end of the fossil fuel
economy this disruption will transform
the lives of every person on the planet
and what's driving it is not pollution
or politics its price
it's soon going to be in everybody's
best selfish economic interest to have
solar panels and batteries and electric
vehicles it's purely economics and
that's how technology disruptions happen
purely economics
[Music]
Tony sibo is a Stanford University
academic and renewable energy investor
who has spent a lifetime studying how
the rise and fall of Technology can
change the world
he believes we are now experiencing one
of the most significant technological
disruptions in modern history
[Music]
a clean disruption which by 2030 will
Herald the end of our current Energy Mix
and the birth of cleaner power in every
corner of the world
there are four essential technologies
that are going to disrupt all of energy
and transportation
batteries solar energy electric vehicles
and autonomous cars and these are all
disruptive in their own way but when you
combine them it's super disruptive it's
exponentially disruptive and that
combination is gonna make all of energy
and transportation obsolete
people fear disruptions but Tony sieber
believes they shouldn't
what happens in disruptions is that
there is a destruction of wealth but
also there's a creation of New Wealth so
the web destroyed a lot of the old
publishing wealth but also if you look
at the top web companies the top
internet companies that's 2.4 trillion
dollars in Market valuation 2.4 trillion
dollars this is the new wealth
Tony is a long-term investor in solar
energy which he believes is leading this
clean disruption whilst it accounts for
barely one percent of world energy today
its growth has been rapid and its costs
are falling
the adoption of solar has been doubling
every two years since 1990 in Australia
there are one and a half million homes
with solar energy that's 25 of the
population
solar in Australia on the rooftop
unsubsidized is cheaper than the cost of
transmission
so think about what that does to the
existing business model of central
generation even if you can generate at
zero in your nuclear or coal plant or
whatever when you have the cost of
transmission you still cannot compete
with solar
Renewables have historically been
plagued by the problem of storage the
ability to keep enough energy in reserve
when the sun doesn't shine and the wind
doesn't blow
but here too the economics are changing
so Lithium-ion batteries are the form of
energy storage that are winning right
now and Lithium-ion batteries have been
improving at about 16 percent per year
on a dollar per kilowatt hour basis so
if you keep that 16
cost curve going essentially by 2020 the
average American household which
consumes more electricity than anyone on
Earth
per capita will be able to store a full
day of electricity for a dollar a day
in Australia it's already becoming
financially viable to store a few hours
of electricity
and within four years five years it's
going to be basically for the cost of a
latte you'll be able to store several
hours of sunshine every day for the cost
of a latte
solar is already
cheaper
unsubsidized than any other form of
energy so we're getting to the Tipping
Point and in technology what happens
with the Tipping Point is that it
accelerates demand accelerates
dramatically and disruptions happen very
quickly the point at which
rooftop solar plus the battery in your
home in your factory in your business in
your hotel becomes cheaper than the cost
of transmission
that is going to happen sometime between
2019 and 2022 everywhere on Earth
this disruption will transform not just
our homes but the way we get from A to B
transportation is undergoing the most
massive disruption in a century
essentially the last time we went
through this disruption was when we went
from horses to electric street cars and
and internal combustion engine cars
which happened a little more than 100
years ago so essentially three things
are going to happen in transportation
are already happening in transportation
all vehicles will go from internal
combustion engine basically fossil fuel
powered to electric vehicles they're
gonna go from 100 human driven
to a hundred percent computer driven and
it's going to go from car ownership to
essentially not owning a car
the implications for companies that
build cars are enormous it could mean
the end of the automotive industry as we
know it
when Vehicles go to all electric
self-driving and car share we're going
to get the same level of service
basically you're going to have a car
picking you up at home taking you to
work and then taking you to the bar and
then taking it to the supermarket and
then back home for 90 percent less cost
and the implications reach far beyond
who build cells and drives cars Tony
believes the design of our cities the
urban fabric of Our Lives could change
forever
now what's going to happen then is that
the number of cars that we need is going
to go down so think about cities like
Los Angeles where 60 percent of the
landmass is parking and Roads
um basically eighty percent of that is
going to be obsolete so this is going to
give us this is going to give the world
for the first time in a century the
possibility to redesign our cities to
totally redesign the landscape how we
want our cities to be
[Music]
taken together these changes amount to
almost a complete revolution in energy
use whilst oil may still be needed for
Aviation and the manufacture of plastics
Tony thinks demand for fossil fuels
fuels which have built the world as we
know it is about to collapse
oil is going to go through what salt
went through in the Middle Ages so 60
percent of petroleum goes into
Transportation 60 that's gone things
like coal gone we're gonna have zero
need for coal things like natural gas
except for fertilizers gone that market
is going to implode totally
it took decades for oil to dominate the
world economy Tony believes the
dominance of renewable energy will
happen much more quickly
when we transitioned from biomass to
Coal to oil and what's so on and so
forth we went from one type of
extraction of mining energy resources to
another in those transitions took a long
time 50 or 100 years but technology
disruptions don't take place in 100
years they take place in months solar is
a technology the energy source is the
sun it's free so we don't need to go
necessarily from one extraction to
another it's basically solar panels
period and the same thing with electric
vehicles it's a technology
the shape of renewable technology is
changing all the time technology now
exists to manufacture transparent solar
panels
now when we think solar we think
rooftops but in the not distant future
and only a few years we'll be able to
convert our windows I mean imagine every
time you look up and you see one of
these high rises
full of windows that could be a three
megawatt solar power plant if all we do
is go through the existing technology
cost curve for batteries and solar and
electric vehicles and autonomous
vehicles
essentially all of energy and
transportation is going to be obsolete
by 2030.
the clean disruption Tony forces has
huge political implications it has the
potential to transform the economies of
entire nations and change the balance of
power across the world
for the Middle East the implications are
massive because when the West does not
value when oil has no strategic value
then are we the West going to be
involved in the Middle East the way
we're involved now no we're not right so
the countries California or Korea or
Germany or China the countries that
leave the clean destruction are going to
be the countries that lead the 21st
century
[Music]
American desert one country is embracing
this bright future
Morocco has just switched on the world's
largest solar power plant
soon energy from these Skies will be
exported to the richest economies in the
world with the potential to transform
the lives of Millions
Tony sieber is an academic and investor
in renewable energy he believes we're in
the midst of a dramatic energy
transition
at the center of this is solar power
enough sun falls on the surface of the
Earth in one hour to power the entire
planet for one year but the technology
needed to capture it store it and Export
it has been problematic
until now
here on the left you can see the norwan
power plants solar power plants so as
you can see you have a very big solar
field with the parabolic mirrors
and you have about 480 hectares of which
is the the total area
[Music]
yes it's the new one solar power plant
in wazazat on the edge of the Sahara
desert in Morocco the first of four
gigantic plants which when finished will
combine to make the largest concentrated
power plant in the world
we have the surface of
1.4 million square meters of mirrors so
it's about 500 000 mirrors
they're separated in seven areas because
of the altitude and because of the water
drainage system
it's going to be enough to provide
energy for two million people
the new project uses new technology to
overcome one of the biggest drawbacks of
solar power the inability to deliver
energy when the sun is not shining
the focal axis in the very center you
have a liquid that is called HTF heat
transfer fluid
so all the the radiation the Rays of the
of the sun are converging in in this
fluid
so you can see there we have two tanks
very big tanks with 45
000 tons
of molten salts that keep the energy
after uh an exchange the heat exchange
with the with the with the HTF for about
three hours so in case we need to
produce electricity after the sunset
we can take this salts and make an
exchange with the HTF and the water to
produce again in the night's electricity
for the future plants that are being
built right now we are we will be able
to produce between seven to eight hours
of extra production during the night
no promises the possibility of 24 hours
solar power
it also promises to transform the
economy of Morocco which Imports 94 of
its energy from abroad
as well as transforming Morocco's
economy solar could turn the nation into
an energy exporter
devices
[Music]
elsewhere in Africa a more modest but no
less significant technology is being
developed
millions of disused plastic bags float
across the South African Countryside
rithaka is a startup which has pioneered
a way of turning this dirty plastic into
clean energy
firstly they bring the Plastics from the
damping site and then we have the
station we call it the washing station
that washing station they wash the
Plastics after we've got the iron that
we ironed that plastic so it's become a
sheet a hot sheet that can that we make
a screw back then we go to a cutting
station where they cut the pattern then
after the pattern it go to the machine
so let's go back
school bags are fitted with a solar
powered charger they charge during the
day and provide light at night
that goes with the school bag so when
the child goes to school it charges on
the Sun so it stays like this
then after
it's going to put it back on the jar
in the afternoon maybe when she's doing
a homework
then we're going to put it back and
it's going to light it
that's how it works the aim is to solve
three problems eliminate a plague of
plastic litter provide light for the
poorer students and provides safe
electricity to families who often use
kerosene or other dangerous fuels to
light their homes
you don't use electricity you don't have
to spend money to use it so it helps a
lot because like the poor people they
use it a lot
[Music]
this Factory is making 500 school bags a
month
it's an example of how energy is moving
away from large-scale utilities into the
hands of small businesses and
individuals
and from fossil fuels to Renewable Power
150 years after the birth of the modern
oil industry are we about to enter a new
era of energy
I think to bet against the renewable
energy sector is Tibet against
modernization it's to bet against
technology it's Tibet against climate
science
and you start to have to make a whole
lot of bets a whole lot of bets that
don't look great by themselves
[Music]
we don't need breakthroughs in solar or
wind we don't need breakthroughs in
autonomous vehicles we don't need
breakthroughs and batteries if all we do
is
take the existing technology cost curve
and the existing improvements of these
Technologies essentially this clean
disruption is going to happen and it's
inevitable and it's going to happen
before 2030.
[Music]
oh